what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and once again we find ourselves hearing
about the possibility of Disney being
bought by Apple a lot of people are
talking about this right now because
recently Bob Iger did say that he is
looking to sell some of the company's TV
and streaming assets and right now
people are talking about him maybe even
considering selling the entire company
now obviously Disney owns Marvel Studios
and lucasfilm Star Wars Etc so if this
did happen this could mean some major
changes could be coming for these
franchises and I know a lot of fans are
panicking right now but there is a lot
of misinformation out there so in this
video we're going to clarify what
exactly Bob Iger said what exactly is
happening right now and the possibility
of Disney being bought by Apple and I
hope this gives you a little bit more
peace of mind first of all let's start
off with what Bob Iger actually said
because a lot of websites are reporting
that Bob Iger put roughly a third of the
company up for sale this week declaring
Disney's linear TV assets non-core to
Disney this is what Bob Iger CEO of
Disney said last week and what people
are now referring to as the Squawk Box
interview this was conducted by David
babber and was held at a media
conference in Sun Valley Idaho now Bob
Iger did talk about the writer strikes
and the actor strikes those have gone
viral but during the interview he talked
about the possibility of selling some
aspects of Disney primarily relating to
TV and streaming services he basically
said that ABC and some of its other
local stations that Disney owns may not
be the core to the Walt Disney Company
and Faber speculated about the possible
sale and Bob Iger said we have to be
open-minded and objective about the
future of those businesses basically
stating yes it is a possibility that we
could sell these but this is essentially
talking about the TV assets mainly ABC
freeform and FX and TV is in Decline
right now because of all the streaming
services live and local television
numbers have obviously been affected
since streaming services have come out
but one thing that he does not say here
that I want to clarify is he says
nothing about the possibility of selling
Disney Plus or selling Marvel Studios or
selling lucasfilm so a lot of people
have mistakenly said recently hey Bob
Iger said that he might sell Marvel
Studios lucasfilm Etc no that is not
what he said the Jeopardy to Marvel
Studios and Star Wars and other
franchises comes at the possibility that
Bob Iger could sell the entire company
to Apple which we'll get into in just a
bit now one thing that has happened
according to Bloomberg Iger wants to
completely sell or restructure Disney's
TV and streaming business in India
specifically so just talking about India
where Disney plus has had the biggest
losses and Disney plus is called hotstar
in India and last quarter they lost 3.8
million subscribers so it's not Disney
plus as a whole that is at risk of being
sold right now it is Disney Plus in
India hot star however Disney plus all
around has suffered some great losses
streaming services for Disney registered
a loss of about 800 million in the last
quarter and in the last quarter Disney
plus lost 4 million subscribers now it's
because of these losses that there's
talk about the whole company possibly
being sold now people have been talking
about this for a long time analysts have
done reports on this plenty of outlets
have talked about it as well and
unfortunately yes it is a possibility
that this could happen and here's where
the massive problem could take place if
this does happen if this happens and
Disney sells to Apple everything that
Disney owns now belongs to Apple unless
Disney sells off some properties and
franchises before they sell but
basically if Apple buys Disney
everything they own goes to Apple and
that does include Marvel Studios
lucasfilm pick XR all of that and here's
where it could be a problem for Marvel
Studios Kevin feige president of Marvel
Studios will now essentially have a new
boss if Disney sells to Apple and since
Marvel hasn't been doing too hot
recently that could mean a big change up
coming to Marvel Studios now Disney is
already planning a pretty big change up
for Marvel as it is and as you can tell
by what's been stated recently
specifically by Bob Iger Disney is
struggling as a whole with all of their
streaming services and in response to
that they are looking to make some major
changes big enough changes to where they
could be selling Disney Plus in India
and they could be selling some of their
other TV assets so this is a very real
thing that they are talking about right
now and strategizing about both Bob Iger
and Kevin feige have come out and
already stated we are going to be
pulling back on content meaning they're
not going to produce as much content
here's what Bob Iger had to say in that
same interview he said there have been
some disappointments we would have liked
some of our more recent releases to
perform better it's reflective not as a
problem from a Personnel perspective but
I think in our Zeal to basically grow
our content significantly to serve
mostly our streaming offerings we ended
up taxing our people Way Beyond in terms
of their time and their focus Way Beyond
where they had been Marvel is a great
example of that they had not been in the
TV business at any significant level not
only did they increase their movie
output but they ended up making a number
of television series and frankly it
diluted focus and attention that is I
think more of the cause than anything so
basically he said they did way too much
they went from not really have any
connected TV series and the series they
did have on Netflix really and Agents of
Shield weren't really that tolling or
taxing on the MCU movie goers but now
they added more movies and added four to
five to six Disney plus projects a year
and fans out there have complained that
it is a lot to keep up with too much to
keep up with and can get pretty tiresome
to keep up with everything especially if
you're not interested in a particular
Disney plus project so now Bob Iger and
Disney as a whole are suffering problems
because of this Disney plus is taking
extreme losses and now the talks of
Apple possibly buying Disney is on the
table again and if this happens like I
mentioned Marvel Studios could kind of
be in trouble because if Apple buys
Disney they could replace Kevin feige
they could literally fire Kevin feige
the Creator the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the man who has shaped the MCU
so far of course he had help John
Favreau and other people were big
players of it but Kevin feige is the guy
and apple could get rid of him they
could say well you haven't exactly done
the best job recently so we're gonna
bring in somebody that we think could be
better and this could really affect the
industry as a whole Apple has its own
streaming service right now this could
be combined with Disney plus which could
severely affect the streaming industry
Apple could gain a pretty big Monopoly
and they're already a pretty big major
player and now people are coming out
stating that Disney could be selling to
Apple stating that they are hearing that
it's on the table and being talked about
right now Disney Insider Scott Gustin
said this rumors have long swirled that
Iger will end up selling all of Disney
to Apple it's still hard to imagine Iger
selling Disney to anyone he's always a
builder not a seller but Bob the Builder
is doing a lot more cutting this time
around in which he is in response to
this Grace Randolph also stated this is
a rumor I am hearing as well not
happening like tomorrow but it's now in
the realm of possible I am very against
Disney being owned by another company I
would prefer they remain independent and
fix their current issues in which I'd
have to agree I don't think they should
sell to Apple I think they are more than
capable of fixing the current issues
that they have and it seems like Bob
Iger and Kevin feige specifically
speaking about Marvel Studios know what
the issues are the TV accents aren't
exactly helping Disney so Bob Iger
stating that they could sell these TV
assets isn't that big of a surprise and
again he's not talking about the
streaming services he is not talking
about selling Disney Plus or Marvel
Studios or lucasfilm he is talking about
those specific TV assets ABC freeform
and FX so as of right now Marvel Studios
is okay lucasfilm is okay Bob Iger isn't
putting those up for sale however it
does seem like the possibility of Disney
selling to Apple is on the table in
which case yes Marvel Studios would be
sold to Apple Apple would own Marvel
Studios and lucasfilm Etc and if that
happens like I said we could be in for a
pretty big shake-up but until then this
is all rumors Disney apparently has
plans to try and fix their own streaming
services to try and cut back and make
better quality content also try to save
some money to where they don't have to
sell but can eventually turn a profit
start making money and stop losing
subscribers but of course if we hear
anything about this we'll be sure to do
an update video so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
video videos also if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month if
you'd like to further support the
channel you can check out our patreon
account you can check out our website
and Discord server and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter we'll
link all of those down below as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf